i've got a square here
say it's right like that and what makes
it a square is all of the sides are
equal and i haven't gone in depth into
angles yet but these are at right angles
to each other i'll just draw it like
that that means that if this bottom side
goes straight left and right that this
left side will go straight up and down
that's all the right angle really means
let's say that
the side down here is equal to
eight meters this side right here and
this is a square and i were to ask you
what is the area
what is the area of the square
well the area is essentially how much
space the square takes up let's say on
your screen right now so it's
essentially a way of measuring a way of
measuring how much space something takes
up and on kind of a two dimensional
surface a two dimensional surface would
just be this computer screen or your
piece of paper if you're also doing this
problem
an analogy would be if you had an eight
meter by eight meter room how much
carpeting would you need is kind of the
size of of the space you need to fill
out in two dimensions on some type of
surface so the area here is literally
how much is this size that you're
filling up it's very easy to figure out
for a square it's literally going to be
your base times your height
this is true for any rectangle but since
this is a square your base and your
height are going to be the same number
so it's going to be 8 meters so your
area is going to be 8 meters
times
8 meters which is equal to 8 times 8 is
64. and then your meters times your
meters you can you have to do the same
thing with your units you get 64 meters
squared or another way of saying this is
64 square meters and you might be asking
where are those 64 square meters well
you can actually break it out here
so let me draw it a little bit bigger
than i originally drew it i probably
should have drawn it this big to begin
with so let's say that's my same my same
square i'm going to draw a little bit
so let me divide it in the middle
let me say i have let me divide them
again
let me divide each side again just like
that
could probably do it neater and let me
do it one more time
divide these
just like
that
and then divide these just like that
there you go
okay now the reason why i did this is to
show you the dimensions along the base
and the height so if you show we said
this is eight meters and notice i have
one two three four five six seven eight
meters and the same thing along the side
meters so when we're talking about 64
square meters we're literally counting
each of the square meters a square meter
is a two-dimensional measurement that's
one meter on each side that's one meter
that's one meter so what i'm shading
here in yellow is one square meter and
you can imagine just counting the square
meters in each row in each row we're
gonna have one two three four five six
seven eight square meters and then we
have eight rows so we're gonna have
eight times eight square meters or 64
meters squared which is essentially if
you sat here and just counted each of
these
you would count 64 square meters
now what happens if i were to ask you
the perimeter
the perimeter of my square
the perimeter of my square the perimeter
is the distance you need to go to go
around the square it's not measuring for
example how much carpeting you need it's
measuring for example if you wanted to
put a fence around your carpet i'm kind
of mixing the indoor and outdoor
analogies it would be how much fencing
you would need so it would be the
distance around so it'd be that distance
plus that distance plus that distance
plus that distance well we already know
this distance right here on the bottom
we already know this distance is eight
meters
and then we know that the height right
here is eight meters
and it's a square this distance up here
is going to be the same as this distance
down here it's going to be another eight
meters
and then when you go down on the
left-hand side that's going to be
another eight meters
we have four sides one two three four
each of them are eight meters
so you add eight to itself four times
that's the same thing as eight times
four you get 36 meters
now notice when we measured just the
amount of amount of fencing we needed we
ended up with just with meters
just with kind of a one-dimensional
measurement and that's because we're not
measuring square meters here we're not
measuring how much area we're taking up
we're measuring a distance a distance to
go around we are taking turns but you
can imagine straightening out this fence
and it would just become one big fence
like this which would have the same
length of 36 meters so that's why we
just have a meters there for perimeter
but for area we got square meters
because we're counting these two
dimensional measurements now let's make
it a little bit more interesting what
happens
what happens if instead of a square i
have a rectangle
i have a rectangle like this
i have a rectangle
let's say that this side over here is
seven
let's say seven centimeters and let's
say
that the height right here
let's say that the height right here is
four
centimeters so what is the area of this
rectangle going to be it's going to be
seven times four centimeters seven
centimeters
times four centimeters remember we could
we could draw e we could draw seven rows
right and each of them is going to have
four square centimeters each of those
are square centimeters so if you were to
count them all out you'd have seven
times four square centimeters it's four
centimeters so it's equal to 28
centimeters squared or squared
centimeters what's the perimeter
what's the perimeter well it's going to
be equal to this distance down here
which is 7 centimeters
plus this distance over here which is
4 centimeters
plus the distance on the top this is a
rectangle it's going to be the same
distance as this one over here so plus
another 7 centimeters and then you're
going to have this distance on the left
hand side
but this distance on the left-hand side
is the same as this distance right here
this is also four centimeters
so plus another four centimeters and
what do you get you get seven plus four
which is eleven and then you have
another seven plus four so you have
eleven plus eleven so you have 22
centimeters once again it's not a square
centimeter
now let's make let's
let's let's divert let's go away from
our rectangle analogy or our rectangle
examples and let's see if we can do the
same with triangles
so let's say i have a triangle here
i have a triangle like this
of a triangle like this and let's say
that this distance right here
actually let me draw it like this i
think this will make it a little bit
easier for you to see how this relates
to a rectangle
let me draw it like this
there you go that's my triangle and
let's say that this distance right here
is seven centimeters
right down there
and let's say that the height of this
triangle
the height of this triangle is 4
centimeters
and i were to ask you what is the area
of the triangle
area
of
the triangle
what is the area of the triangle well
when we had a
rectangle like this we just multiplied 7
times 4. but what would that give us
that would give us the area of an entire
rectangle
if we did 7 times 4 that would give us
the area of this entire rectangle you
can imagine extending
my triangle up like this
this is a right triangle this is going
straight up and down this is going
straight left and right on the bottom
right here you can see it's a 90 degree
angle if you've been exposed to the idea
of angles already so it's you could
almost view it as it's half of this
rectangle and you it's not really almost
it is because when you if you just dump
double this guy you can imagine if you
flip this
triangle over you get this you get the
same triangle but it's just upside down
and flipped over so if you think about
when you multiply 7 times 4 you're
getting the area
you're getting the area of this entire
rectangle you're getting the area of
that entire rectangle which we just did
up here but we want to know the area of
the
triangle we want to know just this area
right here
but you can see hopefully from this
drawing
that the area of this triangle is
exactly half of the area of the entire
rectangle
so the area for a triangle
area for a triangle is equal to
the base times the height
now this so far base times height is the
area of a rectangle so in order to get
the area of the triangle you're going to
multiply that times one-half so one-half
base times height so in our example it's
going to be one-half
times
seven centimeters
times four centimeters
we know what seven times four is or uh
we we already know it's 28 centimeters
we did that up there
so this is this right here is 28
centimeters and then we want centimeters
and we want to multiply that by one-half
so we're going to be 14
centimeters just like that so the area
of this triangle is exactly half of the
area of that rectangle
now the perimeter of this of this
triangle becomes a little bit more
complicated because figuring out
this distance
figuring out that distance right there
isn't the easiest thing in the world
well it will be easy for you once you
get exposed to the pythagorean theorem
but i'm going to skip that right now i'm
going to leave that for the pythagorean
theorem video let me just give you one
more area of a triangle
let's say i have a triangle that looks
like this this was a very special case
that i that i drew to make it look like
half of a rectangle well let's say we
had a triangle that looks like this
it's a little bit more skewed skewed
looking like this
and let's say that this distance down
here
that distance down there
is
three
meters
that distance is three meters
and let's say we don't know we don't
know what that distance is and we don't
know what that distance is but we do
know
we do know that if we were to kind of
drop a line straight down like this if
you imagine this was a building or some
type of mountain and you just drop
something straight down onto the ground
like that we know that this distance is
equal to
let's say it's equal to four
meters
so what is the area of this triangle
going to be
what is the area
of this triangle going to be well we
apply the same formula area is equal to
one-half
base times height so it's equal to
one-half the base is literally this base
right here of this triangle so one-half
times three
times the height of the triangle or i
guess a better way to think of it as an
altitude of the triangle so this thing
isn't even in the triangle but it is
literally the height if you imagine this
was a building you say how high is the
building it would be this height right
there so one half times three times four
you use that distance right there which
is equal to which is you three times
four is twelve times one half is equal
to six
we're going to be dealing with square
meters and i really want to highlight
the idea because if i just if i gave you
a triangle that looked like this
if i gave you a triangle that looked
like this where if this was three meters
down here and then if i were to tell you
that this side
over here
is four meters
this is not you you really this is not
something that you can just apply this
formula to and figure out in fact you'd
have to know some of the angles what not
to really be able to figure out the area
or you'd have to know this other side
here so this is
not easy
not easy you have to know what the
altitude or the height of the triangle
is you need to know this distance in
this case it was one of the sides but in
this case it's not one of the sides
you'd have to figure out what that side
right there on the right hand side is in
order to apply this formula